what's the deal man is $5 son Taylor
Ganga died and these are some of the
videos that make me laugh on YouTube
like some real tight funny [ __ ] all
right so this is the first one is pretty
popular actually played it in the club
now people dancing to it and going crazy
it's called why you always mind why are
you always lie and it's just hilarious
man he just looks like a goober the next
one is called girl falls out of golf
cart while texting it's plenty of [ __ ]
cuz he's just like not even paying
attention don't know how to but really
it's because the driver is a [ __ ]
he's going like 70 miles per hour down a
hill in a golf cart with no doors like
goddamn anybody would have failed so I
can't even blame her oh my god alright
the last video picking up girls in a
Lamborghini without talking
just pull up
do you know that it means the money
speaks for itself hello
man thanks for watching this [ __ ] I hope
you'll love it it's ty dollar signs
Taylor getting to die coming to a
theater near you [ __ ]